there's so much to discover on netflix
ranging from action to horror to science
fiction and beyond
sometimes finding the perfect movie for
your mood can be tough
not to worry we're here to help and
we've spotlighted some hidden netflix
gems that you can add to your must watch
list
fashion designer tom ford scripted and
directed nocturnal animals
a mind-bending and deeply unsettling
thriller in which the plot itself blends
into fears and gets confused with a
story being told by the film's troubled
characters
amy adams plays susan an unhappily
married art gallery owner
who receives a fascinating novel
manuscript called nocturnal animals
written by her vindictive first husband
edward played by jake gyllenhaal
the action in the film shifts to depict
the book a horrifying story about tony
also portrayed by gyllenhaal a man whose
car breaks down in rural texas
just before a gang of criminals kidnaps
his wife and daughter
and leaves him stranded it's up to
detective bobby andes a strong but
silent type to help tony
exact his revenge meanwhile back in
susan and edward's world
viewers learn about the emotional
devastation that led to the demise of
their marriage
neil pond of parade called nocturnal
animals an artsy and grotesquely
gorgeous but hardly an uplifting tale
think no country for old men meet csi
west texas
by way of twin peaks jason momoa looks
like a superhero in real life so it's
logical he gets to play larger than life
figures like aquaman
and physical characters like karl drogo
those roles seem like a natural fit for
mamoa
a digging in braven mama gets the
opportunity to play a regular guy for
once
albeit a regular guy thrust into a
stressful situation
and forced to do heroic things a humble
family man named joe braven
takes his father and daughter to their
cabin in the woods to forget their
troubles for a couple of days
unfortunately they don't get any rest
and relaxation because they run afoul of
drug traffickers who have been using the
bravens property
as a stash house a violent and bloody
standoff ensues as braven fights to
protect his property and his family
joe laden of variety perfectly summed up
the film to put it simply and gratefully
raven is a sort of unpretentious yet
thoroughly professional popcorn
entertainment
that brings out the best in everybody
involved
a monster calls might sound like the
name of a horror movie but it's actually
a spielberg like fantasy
director j.a bayona crafts an
allegorical eye-popping film about all
too real and difficult emotions from the
point of view of a child
which makes it all the more
heartbreaking a monster calls is about
grief but it's also about a walking
talking tree creature
with the voice of liam neeson connor is
13 and his mother is dying he's just old
enough to know what's going
on but young enough to have no idea how
to cope he can't turn to his stern
grandmother for help and his father
isn't a big part of his life
an unlikely and impossible ally arrives
just when conor needs him
he is the monster a massive sentient
utree who offers to tell conor three
grand tales
after that conor must share his own
stories of wild creatures conor o'malley
when you let them lose who knows what
havoc they may read
it's all a little frightening and also
wonderful and the revelation of where
the tree learned his stories
will definitely leave the viewer
misty-eyed which is rare for a movie
about a giant monster who may or may not
be a figment
of a child's imagination television has
been graced with many reality and
game shows that pit a group of strangers
against each other
acquiring a vote to eliminate all but
one last standing champion
alliances are formed but it's ultimately
every person for themselves
the provocative and frightening 2015
film circle
takes the idea and ups the stakes
considerably 50 strangers all facing
execution
are placed in a darkened room and made
to choose among themselves which one of
them shall get to walk out alive
it's us us what do you mean
we're choosing who dies the sparse film
sparse 87 minutes fly by as various
unnamed desperate characters
passionately argue
and bargain on behalf of their own
futures while time and chances run out
of course they also have to fear
immediate eradication by the wicked
forces holding them in the room if they
so much as move
john de four of the hollywood reporter
wrote about the film saying
circle keeps suspense alive building to
a final tableau that silently says
nearly as much about human nature
as does all the talks leading up to it
at the beginning of elizabeth harvest
the film seems like an examination of a
newlywed couple's life
henry and elizabeth kellenberg appear to
be delicately adjusting to life as
married people
elizabeth moves into the wealthy and
prominent henry's beautiful
well-appointed home
filled with luxuries and creature
comforts in the spirit of their new
partnership
henry gives elizabeth free reign over
his house and suggests that they'll live
in wedded bliss so long as she doesn't
go poking around one mysterious room in
the basement
that sounds ominous naturally elizabeth
can't help herself and
investigates the forbidden zone this is
when the film takes a turn and gets
really interesting
she discovers a shocking secret that
sends her down a mysterious path
filled with danger and intrigue with
elements of science fiction and horror
elizabeth harvest is a dark fairy tale
that explores man's darkest impulses
war movies are by their nature action
movies the best ones we create through
events with emotional honesty and
visceral realism
that exposes viewers to an approximation
of the nightmarish world of combat
the outpost is such a movie taking place
during the battle of kamdesh
a crucial and deadly 2009 event in the
ongoing afghanistan war
at the keating combat outpost set in a
valley of three mountains outnumbered
american soldiers fight an onslaught
of well-armed taliban combatants
presented as a series of episodes the
outpost doesn't just recreate an epic
battle from recent history
but it tells a story which allows the
audience to get to know the characters
the members of the troop are mostly just
regular decent people
thrust into a difficult and clearly
terrifying situation
with everything leading up to the can't
look away battle scenes in fact
matt fowler of ign described the outpost
as a cleverly and respectfully crafted
war film
knock knock is a home invasion thriller
with a couple of twists the criminals
have an important if cynical
lesson to teach about the baseness of
men and it's also one of the few movies
where the universally beloved keanu
reeves
plays an unlikable character this
dread-inducing and quick-moving 2015
thriller from writer director eli roth
begins innocuously with a knock on the
door of the beautiful home
of seemingly happily married architect
evan webber because of work obligations
he's home alone with his dog
monkey over father's day while his
family takes a quick vacation
genesis and bell two young flirtatious
women played by lorenza izo
under pre-knives out on a de lamas gain
entry claiming to be lost and looking
for a house party
not everyone would just let two total
strangers into their house these days
well you don't look that dangerous the
women aggressively come on to evan
and he eventually gives in to his base
carnal urges
and that's when the terror and violence
begin knock knock is actually a light
remake of the 1977 b-movie death game
which has gained a cult following in the
years since its release
just like the original the film is
packed with thrills suspense
humor and over-the-top performances
an elite squad of secret operatives
hunting down and punishing those who
committed unspeakable acts of terror
against their community
is a small film genre unto itself and a
good one at that
among such stories one can find as much
action and drama as cathartic psychology
and shocking real world history
in the same vein of steven spielberg's
munich which told the story of israeli
moussar agents going after the
terrorists who killed athletes at the
1972 summer olympics
comes operation finale the film details
the early 60s mission of a team of
highly trained top-secret israeli
operatives
who traveled to argentina in order to
bring to justice adolf eichmann
he was a high-ranking nazi official who
masterminded the logistics of the
holocaust
responsible for the deaths of millions
of jewish people oscar isaac plays
real-life massage agent peter morgan
leading the charge against eichmann mv
moorhead of phoenix magazine called
operation finale
crisp and absorbing and satisfying both
as a thriller and as a moral drama
on one level viewers know exactly what
they're getting when they click on a
movie called
vampires versus the bronx we got
vampires in the bronx
it is indeed a violent tale of creepy
bloodsuckers hailing from eastern europe
in the classic vampire movie style but
this time they're in a modern day urban
setting
specifically one of new york city's five
boroughs however
vampires vs the bronx is so much more
than that it's a socially conscious
celebration of bronx culture
the story of a bunch of smart and
capable kids coming together to save the
day
and a deeply satirical horror comedy the
vampiric real estate agents at the
center of the story represent wealthy
individuals
and businesses that want to gentrify
older neighborhoods
and a scrappy bunch of young people have
to stop them before nothing is left and
no one is alive
don't go there ma he he's a really bad
man
of course he is he's in real estate like
many critics ben travis of empire had
positive things to say about vampires
versus the bronx he called the film a
witty and likable horror comedy that
manages to put a stake to the heart of
some real issues
while it tickles your ribs based on joe
ballerini series of gently spooky kids
novels of the same name
the babysitter's guide to monster
hunting is a family-friendly movie
directed by rachel talalay
a filmmaker best known for her work on
tank girl and the nightmare on elm
street series
ballerini and talalay were the ideal
combo to make what could be a kid's
first horror comedy
a dark funny and twisted take on the 80s
classic
adventures in babysitting teenage
babysitter kelly gets a gig looking
after a kid on halloween night
that's a bummer in and of itself made
worse when the kid is kidnapped by the
actual boogeyman
kelly has to do her best to rescue the
little guy luckily she's helped along
the way in her fight against monsters
goblins and pure evil by a secret
society of elite
and well-equipped babysitters i hate
babysitters
nell minnow of movie mom said the film
delivers gorgeously imagined settings a
great cast
and an exciting story that hits the
exact sweet spot between funny scary and
scary funny
the twelfth man is a war movie a
survival tale and amazingly
it's also a true story john bowsrud
worked for the norwegian resistance
during nazi germany's occupation of his
country
during world war ii trained as a
commando by the british military
battlesrud attempts an escape to neutral
sweden following a sabotage mission gone
wrong
to get to freedom he has to face the
punishing weather of scandinavia in the
winter
the norway-based nazis however noticed
almost immediately that baal's rudders
disappeared and chased him through the
icy mountains
where conditions are so severe that
frostbite and hypothermia
may claim him first among many other
positive reviews
frank scheck of the hollywood reporter
wrote the 12th man improves consistently
engrossing and suspenseful
with its lead performances further
enhancing its impact
the best horror movies consist of a lot
more than just a few jump scares and
some terrifying form of bone-chilling
menace
the good ones reflect and comment upon
the everyday things that trouble human
beings
little evil is that kind of movie it's a
horror comedy with the emphasis on
comedy
about an eager to please guy who marries
a woman who has a son from a previous
marriage
he's desperate to connect with the
inscrutable little guy so his
relationship can thrive and they can all
come together as a happy family
that's a difficult task as a kid is
actually the spawn of satan and he's not
afraid to unleash pure evil and terror
on his well-meaning new step-dad and
that's where the horror comes into play
that same with a creepy hand puppet
named reroy i'm your stepfather now
yeah okay um we'll just talk later or
whenever you want
amanda sink of the hollywood outsider
perfectly described the film in one line
little evil is the omen by way of shaun
of the dead
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
movies on netflix are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you